help us change the culture by buying our
latest single from tim cast records only
ever wanted by clicking the link in the
description below
we have this from newsweek it's from
richie mcginnis he's a good friend of
the show says i was in kenosha two years
ago kyle rittenhouse is not a hero
there's a lot to go through in his op-ed
to understand his position
he says before the shooting started 11
36 p.m on august 25th 2020 i ran into
kyle rittenhouse in front of a gas
station and interviewed him for several
minutes
he was a 17 year old kid with a
semi-automatic rifle and he was playing
cops surrounded by people who didn't
want him there rent house didn't see it
that way quote so people are getting
injured and our job is to protect this
business and part of my job is also to
help people
he told me for the third night in a row
half of downtown kenosha was a blaze
when there's somebody hurt i'm running
into harm's way 13 minutes later
rittenhouse standing feet from me would
kill one man a few minutes after that
he'd kill another then he'd maim a third
interesting thing is
uh well actually you know
unless we have to like read the whole
piece i'm not gonna do it richie
mentions that he was he remained neutral
kept his opinion to himself so that he
could be a witness on the stand and he
and he pushed back when you know the
defen when the when the prosecutors
tried claiming you know that written
house wasn't being threatened he was
like you know rosenbaum said f you and
then reached for the gun things like
that
but he he richie
drew you were there and you read this
article so like you should give your
position and give yourself i was in the
trial too like i'm not going to
attack richie here right richie can have
his own opinion that's fine that's cool
but i was there too okay i saw the same
exact things i watched joseph rosenbaum
get shot i was right behind richie when
he put rosenbaum in the back of the
ambulance all that same trauma they were
hitting him i witnessed two yes i
witnessed the two all that same trauma
but
the real question here is
is kyle rittenhouse really the villain
and this goes back to the point i was
trying to make is what happens when law
and order pulls back
are you left to defend yourself
are you left to defend your own
community because that's what happened
in kenosha
i wasn't there on night two
and i wasn't just there on night three i
showed up night one
i blew up that story that went worldwide
the kenosha riot that was my footage so
when i speak on this no one can talk
about kenosha without talking about the
context of kenosha right jacob blake got
himself shot they started throwing
bricks at police officers heads i showed
up on the scene that night they were
burning down kenosha period it was not a
protest there were no protesters and the
rioters are the ones that showed up with
guns and were pointing them at police
officers for three consecutive nights
they did this they burnt down multiple
car dealerships okay they were burning
committing arson looting the whole nine
yards the police were being told to
stand down this is why the community in
the area if you guys remember they were
boarding up the windows and they were
writing things like hey elderly people
live here the handicapped live here you
want to know why because that little
community thought they were going to die
because of these rioters all right there
was an old man who got bashed over that
with a rock exactly but this is filmed
when you talk about when you talk about
why kyle rittenhouse was in kenosha this
you have to talk about this stage that
led to people showing up oh banging on
the table wait so oh yeah but
sorry this isn't my show you're feeling
this um but but it goes through the
microphone yeah you have to talk about
what why was he even in kenosha right
and they always say oh you see he
crossed state lines he caught well
antifa on night two after the first
night of rioting we're literally
mobilizing from portland and seattle to
cross state lines multiple rights
multiple multiple i want to so i want to
point something out here this gets to
the heart of the argument this is an
article from richie and he brings up
something interesting he says protesters
kept trying to climb into the suv this
is after rosenbaum got shot i couldn't
see who was punching me but the blows
kept coming i kicked someone trying
furiously crazily to grab onto the rear
bumper as we raced to the hospital when
we finally got there we stopped at the
bottom of a ramp leading to the er i
tried not to cry as we waited for the
metal security door to open it's gonna
be okay bro i told rosenbaum we're gonna
have a beer after this and laugh about
it it was hard to hear my voice over the
sounds of rosenbaum struggling to
breathe and gargling blood instead
as we pulled it to the hospital i
watched gays i watched gage gross crates
limp through its doors a police officer
held his butchered arm it was a mangled
mess of flesh and bone not fully
amputated but not quite an arm i didn't
know the time but anthony hoover was
lying dead in the pavement just outside
the hospital so here's what here's what
i see here
i think richie is affected emotionally
by this yeah and i was just gonna say
that and from my perspective having been
someone who was not there but who
interviewed all of you guys and on more
than one occasion i hear a story and
i've seen footage and i've heard a trial
and i see a man rosenbaum who threatened
to kill a 17 year old kid more than once
and then tried to make good on that by
reaching for the weapon the moment he
reached for that weapon he created the
threat of deadly force against kyle
because if he got control of that of
that muzzle
and then started fighting kyle who knows
what happened a gunshot went off behind
kyle
now all he knows is a guy is chasing me
who threaten to kill me someone's
shooting and i don't know where and he
turns around and what does he get
rosenbob tries to grab the gun
richie's affected by that saying we're
going to have beers together i get it
i've i've i've seen some horrifying
stuff not nearly that level but i've
seen people die i've seen people be
seriously injured and i can certainly
understand why richie was looking at
that and like on the verge of tears be
like we're going to grab beers bro from
an outside perspective looking at this
from a mathematical logical standpoint
that makes no sense this is a guy who
was trying to who's threatening to kill
someone and attack them why you would
want to get beers at them as if they're
the victim when they're the aggressor
i'm not happy that this happened to him
i'm not happy that kyle was there i
think even kyle said he probably
wouldn't have gone you know in hindsight
or something like that i'm not happy
that somebody lost their life but i'm
not gonna sit here and be like i'm gonna
shed a tear over the guy who instigated
violence threatening to kill somebody
like we we have to recognize violence is
wrong it sucks it's bad and then we have
to recognize rosenbaum initiated it he
was the one who was doing the bad and we
were lucky that kyle was able to defend
himself we it was unfortunate for
everybody that it played out this way
well joseph rosenbaum said shoot me
n-word multiple times and was requesting
to get shot so he got his death wish he
got what he wanted because he was there
committing crimes literally five minutes
before that took place joseph rosenbaum
not only requested to be shot okay but
he was committing arson right before
they even got to that car dealership
where that all took place so people
understand it's like kyle was
administering
uh first aid on both sides he even
admitted that under oath in the trial as
well so like it's like
you have to understand the the i always
make this point
these were not good people these were
not good people these people were a
threat to the community they always will
be they always have been because they
were rioting and committing mass
violence for consecutive nights joseph
rosenbaum was not a good guy and the guy
was asking to be shot saying the n-word
at a so-called blm protest i don't feel
sorry for that no one cared nobody
nobody cared that he was doing it to
your point drew i mean i think maybe a
better title of the article would be you
know kyle rittenhouse isn't a hero but
they are not victims either um and the
part of the article that i thought was
really interesting and poses a lot of
good questions was later on when when
richie talks about kyle rittenhouse
gaining national fame right and being
put up on stages and inhaled as a hero
um you know like you said drew the
police were told to stand down should
there be some sort of community action
where people do go out and protect their
businesses protect their homes should it
be an 18 year old with an ar-15
you know with the police standing down i
don't know right if there's no law in
order if there's no police presence then
is it in the hands of the citizens to
take action should an 18 year old go out
there some people would say yes then 18
year olds should arm up and go out and
protect their communities
it's an interesting question and i don't
have the answer to it i think destroying
someone's home is one of the worst
crimes you could ever commit killing
someone is probably the worst just
breaking someone's body destroying
someone's body probably the worst
destroying someone's home
is probably the next worst crime
absolutely
death like death penalty kind of stuff
like if someone goes to a city and burns
the city down that's you essentially
destroyed 100 million people like over
10 million people i'm over here all
anti-death penalty and ian's like that's
penalty for ryan why not let people
destroy people's homes i mean this goes
back 100 000 years of
torching villages and things that's like
the worst thing if you're killing people
and even if you're just destroying their
homes and sending them off in a no man's
land like that's also horrific to do to
a human so i think that the problem i'm
into death penalty and i think it's
because the state can never definitively
prove
that you know they have the right person
there's a risk there of giving them the
authority but the idea of defending
yourself from someone trying to burn
down your home now that's a more
interesting question
i'm fairly certain that if you are in
your house
almost every state and someone is trying
to set fire to it you they are trying to
use lethal force against you and that
would that would justify the use of
lethal force in kind west virginia
especially if you're in west virginia
and someone comes with a molotov
cocktail to throw at your house and
they're about to throw it you are
justified in using lethal force to
defend yourself a lot of states have
codified that destroying someone's home
is one of the worst things you can do
and that you can shoot on site if they
step onto your property a lot of states
have those gun rights some states maybe
are a little more lenient well the
article always also attacked turning
point usa for you know bringing kyle on
stage and you know we we really wanted
to
have like a celebration for him that's
what that was and it's like
that's that's okay you know this is this
is kind of like this falls under the
category of the new right right it's
like where no one's trying to make him a
celebrity it's like
we we had a w
okay we got a w with that
because not only did he defend himself
not only did what he do what he did was
right to defend himself in that moment
in the context of everything happening
but even the trial itself with all the
defamation saying he shot black people
president joe biden coming out saying
he's the literally the poster boy of
white supremacy okay the deep state and
these powers went after him hard pure
defamation okay that same playbook that
gets put on everybody
kyle won
kyle won because god was on his side and
he was acting in truth and righteousness
the the point i'm trying to make is
the reason why
we wanted to celebrate that is because
we have to at this point we have to how
many l's like aren't people sick of just
continually taking l's to these people
continually letting the deep state win
continually letting them just go after
anyone that's a freedom lover or a
patriot it's like every single time they
get what they want we finally had hope
where honestly i i thought kyle was
probably going to be put away
yeah the way things were going the way
things always go these people always win
they always win they always get a w so
so you i'm sorry that we decided to
celebrate our w for once in a while
because righteousness won and justice
one when kyle was vindicated because
what he did was not wrong we are going
to celebrate that american america is
going to celebrate that because it was
the little guy versus big brother that's
what that trial was and the little guy
won america one justice won and we will
celebrate that and we will not be
apologetic the the the the culture war
right
struggles to organize properly
consistently it's stuff like that
because someone comes out and criticizes
like oh oh far be it from us that we
celebrate something like that because we
have to look all good no no those days
are over look around look how long it
took joe rogan to be like okay maybe he
should vote republican exactly i mean
for all the thing that that
joe's talked about that he's criticized
he's still maintained that you know he's
a liberal or whatever we've not heard it
until recently he's like okay maybe you
should vote republican well i think
if you look back at everything joe told
me
you know before uh or not before the
election but i mean even even still
before the election if you look at the
things he was talking about during the
pandemic you'd think he'd have come out
sooner and been like guys you maybe
should vote republican like is th is the
is the issue with joe
uh for joe that
he he only just realized the mistakes
were made right so he's talking to aaron
rodgers and he says mistakes were
seriously made during the pandemic did
joe not know that during the pandemic
that he wouldn't come out hard and be
like guys these lockdowns are wrong you
need to vote out these people who are
doing it and it is the democrats
overwhelmingly who are doing it he
didn't say that it's now he's saying and
he's saying it with a laugh and so i
look at that
and then i look at like
there's there's limited organizational
power but we're working really hard
parallel economy
i'm i've never been happier right
parallel economy dan bingino founded its
financial transactions censorship
resistant the cultural stuff the daily
wire is doing they're they're making
movies they you know they brought gina
carano on they've got more projects in
the works what is a woman with an
amazing documentary
we've got us we rumble everything rumble
is doing
but that's the big challenge right now
the component that you have to compete
with these institutions the media
apparatus is microscopic it's it's it's
tiny and so everything has to be done
across the board to build out these
industries
to build out a space that has money
so that people can be hired so that
people can be like you know if someone
gets fired from their job for speaking
out there's a place for them to go if
you know i'll tell you this taylor
silverman the this female skateboarder
we hired her and i'm excited because
we're going to have her lead our skate
projects
she was one of the first in the
skateboarding industry to come out and
be like hey this is not okay that
biological males are competing against
us how am i supposed to make a living
competing when i'm at this disadvantage
for these reasons and they attacked her
relentlessly and so i responded with
we're going to do our best to make sure
that you're not left left hanging
because you decided to do what was right
too many people are like if i stand up
no one has my back
how can that be how can we we we cannot
accept that the daily wire brought on
gina carano when they try destroying her
career the daily wire has your back they
can't carry everyone
we've hired and worked with a few people
in similar situations
you know pete pirata when the offspring
fired him i thought we got lucky pizza
he's such an amazing guy and he's such a
you know he's been in all these
different bands we're lucky and taylor
silverman i can't look at that and then
be like we're going to ignore you when
you do the right thing no we gotta we
gotta
make sure we're helping people in this
regard otherwise what happens is kyle
goes to jail yeah if if there was no
support for him if people didn't come
out and and now you know and i'll say
this when richie was criticizing turning
point usa i'm glad turning point brought
him out i'm glad they clap and cheer for
him this dude's not gonna have a normal
job ever again what is kyle right now
supposed to do with his life after being
attacked and lied about to this degree
you think he can apply to be a theater
at an amc they're going to be like no
way we're not going to hire you so he
needs to be able to live somehow and
then bringing him up and saying talk to
us is one way to help make that happen i
see it's not about it
it was not about like because you always
see you see this from from from the left
always oh the the new star of the far
right kyle written it's like it's it's
it's not that that's not th this is this
is literally what tim just said
it's coming alongside someone
that literally almost got obliterated
literally obliterated
okay
physically possibly god knows what
rosenbaum was going to do if he got a
hold of his gun and took it probably
would have right okay so this is this is
coming alongside
of of a kid who almost lost his life in
many ways and showing him support
showing him support that that's what
it's about okay like just to give you
guys some some some some background
stuff okay
kyle wants a normal life he'll never
have a normal life
he he didn't ask for this
he he just simply wants to live as
normal as he possibly can
okay like whenever i talk to him he's
just you know just like a normal teenage
young man growing up and right now
we we don't want that we we don't want
some some huge you know famous career
for this guy we we just came alongside
of him because we saw someone that
literally almost got obliterated and
destroyed by the deep state so we
decided to show him support i know
charlie kirk agrees with that i know
everyone that was on that stage agrees
with that because we saw exactly what
happened to him and that's what we
wanted and also
his family his mom at the time
devastated imagine being a mother seeing
your child like literally being put in
that kind of position to lose his life
entirely almost i mean he did the right
thing
he did the right thing but so we decided
to come alongside and show them like hey
you're not alone they want you to feel
like you're alone they want every single
person watching this to feel like
they're alone and we're not going to do
that anymore thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there